Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dansScienceClic,
le champ électromagnétique.
Imaginons deux personnes, dans le vide del'espace,
qui s'échangent une balle.
Au moment d'envoyer la balle, le premier
individuva s'imprimer une certaine vitesse de recul,
car il donne son énergie à la balle.
De même,au moment de la recevoir,
l'autre personne va absorber le mouvement de la balle,
et doncégalement ressentir une vitesse de recul.
En s'échangeant la balle,
les deux individusont accéléré.
Ils étaient au départ immobiles,
ils sont maintenant en mouvement,
ils s’éloignentl’un de l’autre avec une certaine vitesse.
S'ils continuent de s'échanger la balle,
leurs vitessesrespectives vont à chaque fois augmenter,
et ils vont s'éloigner toujours de plus en plusvite.
Tout se passe comme s'ils
subissaient une force qui les repousse,
l’action de la ballepeut être
synthétisée par une force de répulsion.
Dans la nature, à l'échelle quantique,
cemême phénomène est à l'œuvre
entre certaines particules, comme les électrons,
qui sont sanscesse en train de s'échanger des photons virtuels.
Un photon virtuel est une particule
issue deslois de la physique quantique,
qui a le droit d’apparaître à partir de rien,
à condition qu’elledisparaisse suffisamment
vite pour qu’il soit absolument impossible de la détecter.
Un photonvirtuel possède une certaine énergie,
et sa durée de vie est d’autant plus
courte que son énergieest importante.
Ainsi, moins un photon virtuel est énergétique,
c’est à dire plus son énergie est faible,
plus il pourra parcourir une grande distance.
En s'échangeant des photons virtuels,
les électrons ressentent une répulsion, une force qui les repousse,
un peu comme le cas des deux
personnes qui s’échangeaient la balle.
Cette force est d'autant plus puissante
que les électronssont rapprochés l’un de l’autre,
car les photons virtuels ont alors moins de distance à parcourir,
et ils peuvent ainsi être plus énergétiques.
Les électrons ne sont pas les seules
particulesà interagir de la sorte.
Beaucoup d’autres particules
s’échangent des photons virtuels,
et on appelle cette tendance
qu'ont certaines particules à interagir,
leur charge électrique.
L'électron possède une charge électrique de -1e.
“e” représente simplement l’unité
de basepour la charge électrique,
une particule va avoir comme charge électrique
un multiple de cettebrique élémentaire.
Certains objets interagissent davantage qu’un électron,
on peut imaginer unobjet qui en contient deux,
et dont la charge électrique serait alors de -2e.
De plus, certainesparticules, comme le proton,
interagissent avec les photons virtuels de façon opposée,
leurcharge électrique est alors positive,
la charge du proton est par exemple de +1e.
Tout comme lesélectrons,
deux particules de charge positive vont se repousser.
Mais une particule négative
avecune particule positive vont s'attirer.
Ainsi, les charges de même signe se repoussent,
tandis que les charges opposées s'attirent.
Pour prendre en compte toutes ces interactions
on introduit la notion de champ électrique.
Pour ce faire, on peut imaginer une sorte
de tissuimaginaire qui remplirait tout l'espace.
Si on place un électron, de charge négative,
le champva se colorer en bleu autour de lui.
A l’inverse, si on place un proton,
de charge positive, lechamp va se colorer en rouge.
De façon naturelle, les particules vont s’échapper
des zonesqui possèdent la même couleur qu’elles.
Une particule neutre,
sans charge électrique,ne va rien ressentir,
elle va se déplacer en ligne droite comme si de rien n’était.
Maisune charge électrique positive, comme un proton,
va être repoussée par les zones rouges,
etattirée par les zones bleues.
A l’inverse, une charge négative est attirée par les zonesrouges,
et repoussée par les zones bleues.
Illustrons le champ électrique avec plusieursexemples.
Voilà le champ créé par deux électrons :
on voit par exemple que la position centrale,
entre les deux électrons,
est une position d’équilibre.
Si on y place une particule,
celle-ciresterait immobile,
un peu comme une bille entre deux bosses.
Voilà maintenant le champ créé parun électron et un proton,
on voit que les deux particules s’attirent,
le champ électrique formeune sorte de pont de l’une vers l’autre.
Enfin, en plaçant une chaîne d’électrons
d’uncôté, et une chaîne de protons de l’autre,
on peut créer un champ électrique uniforme,
c’està dire qu’une particule dans ce champ
ressentirait toujours la même force où qu’elle soit.
De cettefaçon on peut par exemple mettre
en mouvement les électrons à l'intérieur d'un fil électrique,
c'est ce qu'on appelle un courant électrique.
C’est alors qu’entre en jeu une expériencetroublante.
Imaginons un fil électrique, composé
d’une très longue chaîne de protons etd’électrons,
dans lequel s’écoule un courant électrique.
Le courant électrique correspondsimplement
à un déplacement des électrons le long du fil.
Imaginons qu’on place unobjet à une certaine distance du fil,
par exemple une pomme, qui possède
unecertaine charge électrique positive.
D’après les interactions qu’on a vues précédemment,
chaque proton dans le fil repousse la pomme,
car leurs charges sont toutes deux positives.
Mais en même temps,
chaque électron attire la pomme avec la même intensité.
Globalement,quand on fait la somme de toutes ces forces,
celles-ci se compensent parfaitement,
etla pomme ne ressent au total aucune force.
Effectivement, quand on l’observe,
elle reste bel et bien immobile.
Mais on va maintenant lui donner
une vitessede déplacement vers la droite.
Étrangement, on observe alors que la pomme
est progressivementrepoussée par le fil.
Alors qu’elle ne ressent aucune force électrique,
tout se passe comme si une autre force, mystérieuse,
agissait en secretsur la pomme, la repoussant du fil.
Cette nouvelleforce est un peu particulière.
Elle n’agit pas quand la pomme est immobile,
mais seulementquand elle est en mouvement.
De plus, cette force dépend de la direction
et de la vitesse àlaquelle se déplace la pomme.
On appelle cette force étonnante,
qui apparaît lorsque des chargesélectriques se déplacent,
la force magnétique.
Pour comprendre l’origine de cette force,
il vaêtre nécessaire d’étudier
ce que nous enseigne la relativité restreinte.
Pour commencer, on vaobserver
la situation non pas d’un point de vue extérieur,
mais plutôt telle qu’elle est perçuepar notre pomme,
on va se placer dans son point de vue.
Par rapport au point de vue de la pomme,
ce n’est pas elle qui se déplace vers la droite,
mais le fil qui se déplace vers la gauche.
D’aprèsla relativité restreinte,
plus un objet se déplace rapidement,
plus sa longueur va être contractée,
dans le sens du mouvement.
Dans notre expérience, les protons dans le fil
sont maintenanten mouvement par rapport à la pomme,
ils se déplacent vers la gauche.
Ils vont ainsiêtre contractées dans la longueur du fil,
et tout se passe comme si les protons
s’étaient légèrementrapprochés les uns des autres.
A l’inverse, les électrons semblent
maintenant se déplacerplus lentement.
Ils ont perdu un peu de vitesse,
car le fil tout entier se déplace maintenant versla gauche.
Ils sont donc légèrement étirés
par rapport au point de vue précédent,
et tout sepasse comme si les électrons
s’étaient éloignés les uns des autres.
Globalement, quand on fait
la somme des forces qui s’exercent sur la pomme
de son point de vue, celles-ci ne se compensentplus.
Il y a davantage de charges
électriques positives, des protons, dans le fil,
quede charges négatives.
Et par conséquent,
le fil en entier va exercer une force répulsive sur lapomme,
qui va progressivement l’en éloigner.
En prenant en compte la relativité restreinte,
on s’aperçoit que le champ électrique
généré par une charge se déforme
quand celle-ci se meten mouvement.
Ce phénomène entraîne l’apparition
d’une nouvelle force, la force magnétique,
quin’est en fait qu’une simple force électrique,
mais perçue selon un point de vue différent.
De façon analogue au champ électrique,
on peut résumer tous ces
comportements parun autre champ,
le champ magnétique.
Quand une charge électrique se déplace,
ellecrée autour d’elle un champ magnétique,
qu’on peut représenter par des flèches qui
tournent autour de la direction de son mouvement.
La force magnétique est une conséquence
dela relativité restreinte, et par conséquent
le comportement du champ magnétique est plutôtétrange.
Dans un champ magnétique,
une particule immobile ne ressent aucune force.
Par contre, uneparticule en mouvement va ressentir une force,
qui est d’autant plus importante que laparticule se déplace perpendiculairement à la direction du champ magnétique.
Cetteforce va avoir tendance à faire tourner les particules
suivant des trajectoires en hélices eten cercles,
dont la taille dépend de leur masse,
de leur vitesse, de l’intensité du champ,
ou encore de leur charge électrique.
Bien qu’il est difficile à visualiser,
onpeut se donner une certaine intuition
du champ magnétique en imaginant l’expériencesuivante.
On enroule un fil sur lui-même, de sorte à former une longue bobine,
et onapplique dans ce fil un courant électrique.
En se déplaçant à l’intérieur du fil, chacun desélectrons
va créer autour de lui un petit champ magnétique.
Globalement tous ces petits champs
magnétiques vont s’additionner,
formant au total un champ à grande échelle
qui forme une sorte deboucle,
sortant par une extrémité de la bobine,
et rentrant par l’autre extrémité.
De cette façon,
notre bobine se comporte comme une sorte d’aimant,
c’est-à-dire un objet qui possède
un pôlenord et un pôle sud magnétiques.
On appelle ce genre d’objet, un électroaimant.
Pour lesaimants comme pour les charges électriques,
les pôles de même type se repoussent,
tandis que les pôles opposés s’attirent.
Au centre de la bobine,
le champ magnétique estrelativement uniforme,
il est à peu près le même partout,
dirigé suivant l’axe d’enroulementdu fil.
Si on lance un électron et un proton,
les deux particules vont former des trajectoires
circulaires à cause du champ magnétique,
mais dans des sens opposés car l’électron
est négatif, alors que le proton est positif,
et avec des amplitudes différentes,
carl’électron est moins massif que le proton.
Mais en général la plupart des aimants
nenécessitent pas de courant électrique pourfonctionner.
Certains aimants possèdent
naturellement un champ magnétique,
c’est ce qu’on appelle des aimantspermanents.
Pour comprendre, les particules élémentaires comme l’électron
possèdent unepropriété importante
en physique quantique, qu’on appelle le spin.
Même si ce n’est pas laréalité,
on peut en quelque sorte interpréter le spin
comme une rotation de la particule surelle-même.
En tournant sur elle-même,
la particule engendre une sorte de courant électrique,
quicomme dans le cas de la bobine,
va générer un champ magnétique.
Les particules élémentaires
secomportent ainsi comme de tout petits aimants,
et en les regroupant de façon alignée,
onpeut ainsi créer des matériaux aimantés.
Enfin, pour conclure,
les champs électriques etmagnétiques étant indissociables,
l’un étant à la base de l’autre,
il est naturel de les unifier
en une seule notion, le champ électromagnétique.
Ce champ électromagnétique se comporte
et évolued’une façon bien déterminée,
qu’on peut résumer en quatre principes fondamentaux.
C’est ce qu’onappelle techniquement les 4 équations de Maxwell.
La première équation nous dit qu’une charge
agit comme une source pour le champ électrique.
La deuxième équation, nous dit qu’à l’inverse,
il ne peut pas exister de charges magnétiques,
c’est-à-dire des objets qui neposséderait
qu’un pôle Nord sans pôle Sud,ou vice versa.
Un pôle Nord magnétique
vienttoujours nécessairement avec un pôle Sud,
et si on essaie de couper un aimant
en deux, pour séparer ses deux pôles,
on se retrouve forcément
avecdeux nouveaux aimants plus petits.
Les deux dernières équations traduisent
la façon dont évoluent les champs électrique et magnétique
l’un par rapport à l’autre.
La première de ces deux équations nous ditqu’une variation
de champ magnétique vaperturber le champ électrique.
Si l’on déplaceun aimant à l’intérieur d’une bobine de fil,
on fait varier le champ magnétique,
ce qui perturbe le champ électrique,
et va mettre en mouvement les électrons.
De cette façon, en secouant un aimant à l’intérieur d’une bobine,
on peut générerun courant électrique.
On parle d’induction, car une variation de champ magnétique
peutinduire un courant électrique dans un fil.
Cette technique est largement utilisée,
parles éoliennes, les centrales nucléaires,
ou encore dans les téléphones,
pour convertirdu mouvement en un signal électrique.
Enfin, la quatrième équation nous dit qu’uncourant électrique,
ou plus généralement une variation de champ électrique,
entraîne elle-mêmeune perturbation du champ magnétique.
Cette dernière équation est cruciale,
car elle reboucleavec l’équation précédente.
En effet, faire varier un champ
électrique perturbe le champ magnétique,
mais cette perturbation du champ magnétique
va à son tour perturber le champ électrique.
Cettealternance,
entre champs électrique et magnétique,
permet à l’énergie électromagnétique
de sepropager dans l’espace,
sous la forme d’une onde
qui se déplace à la vitesse des photons virtuels,
c’est ce qu’on appelle une onde électromagnétique,
dont font partie les micro-ondes,
les rayonsX, les infrarouges, ou encore la lumière.
Pour finir, un grand nombre d'expériences
intéressantes sont expliquées par les lois de l'électromagnétisme,
on peut même en quelquesorte ralentir la gravité.
Pour ce faire, il suffit de lâcher
un aimant au-dessus d'unebobine de fil.
Au départ l'aimant tombe
de plus en plus vite car il subit l'attraction de laTerre.
Mais en se rapprochant de la bobine,
son mouvement fait varier le champ magnétiqueau niveau du fil.
Cette variation de champ magnétique
va mettre en mouvement les électronsà l’intérieur du fil,
la chute de l'aimant génère ainsi
un courant électrique dans la bobine.
Maiscomme on l'a vu précédemment,
une bobine parcourue d'un courant électrique
génère elle aussiun champ magnétique,
un peu comme un aimant.
Ce nouveau champ magnétique va venir s'opposer
légèrement au mouvement de l'aimant qui tombe,
et ainsi ralentir sa chute.
À l'intérieurde la bobine, l'aimant tombe plus lentement.